we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's
something interesting from troy york
troy says that rush limbaugh
mentioned the show recently now Troy
York often calls it in lies but he also
sometimes tells the truth and he does
listen to rush take a listen to what
Troy said and then I'm going to ask you
for help finding this and also Dave I
wanted it let you know that Rush
Limbaugh I was listening to his show he
was talking about the Kansas Owens
Democrat leftist socialist Ted Lou and
the c-span how that was a most viewed
and c-span video and and he mentioned
your name
he said that liberals can't believe that
Candace Owen over pretty much roll over
ted Lieu and gave it to him but then he
said that guys like David Pakman made up
then said Candace look bad and he called
you pretty much in [ __ ] idiot in so
many words that you should replay his
show he mentioned David Pakman yeah I
don't know if Troy York is telling me
the truth but if that's the case I would
love to hear that commentary from Rush
Limbaugh so please help us track it down
I'm guessing it has to be sometime
between I believe it was when Tuesday or
Wednesday of last week when the candice
owens ted Lieu thing happened between
then and I guess Friday because Ted Lou
a rather Troy York led that left the
message over the weekend help us track
that down and we we actually do have
evidence that Rush Limbaugh listens to
the David Packard show because he once
did a commentary where he didn't list us
by name but he described the show and
talked about how we were clueless about
I don't know what it was we covered it
and it got like a million views on
YouTube so there was already
pre-existing evidence that Rush Limbaugh
is aware of the David Pakman show as I
dropped my pen and watches the David
Pakman show every once in a while so
please help us determine whether Rush
really did criticize me around the ted
Lieu candice owens thing i would love to
see that send it in and we will thank
you and feature the clip on the show
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about a police officer
being excused
after mistakenly using his gun instead
of a Taser we will talk about a man
suing his parents over his massive porn
collection very odd story and I have to
do one of my my rants that some people
love and some people hate do people not
know how to cough in public anymore I've
got some stories from the weekend in Las
Vegas related to that don't miss today's
bonus show become a member become a
patron